Wonderful. Okay.
Jake Flomenberg, thank you so much
for being on my show
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Good. How are you?
Great.
Where are you calling from right now?
I'm calling from Sunny Menlo Park.
Wonderful.
So, we're very very close by neighbors.
But with this covid situation,
it doesn't matter if we're two miles apart
or a thousand miles apart.
So, either way, thank you for being here.
Very brief overview.
And then we're gonna spend,
we're gonna do a deep dive
into your experiences.
So, you did UPenn.
And then Harvard MBA.
Went on to working
with the founders of Cloudera
is, I think, the first business hire.
And then running the Splunk UI product,
which I've used extensively,
back in my years of engineering in the IDF
and now moved on to
being a venture capital partner
at Accel Ventures and Wing VC.
Did I get that somewhat right?
Roughly correct.
Wonderful.
Jake, I still can't do enough service
to the incredible background
that you have.
I'd love you to tell me
a little bit more about yourself.
And then I'd really love to pick your brain
on these experiences.
Moving from engineering,
working with incredible startups early on,
like Cloudera and Splunk.
And then making that smooth transition
into venture capital.
And some of your insight
into your investment thesis
and how you approach
different opportunities.
Sure. So, why don't I give you sort of
a quick rundown on my background.
And a few of the transition points
I went through.
So, first, I actually did my undergrad
at Duke. I did sort of hardware,
software and engineering,
and said to myself,
"Hey, how can I try to solve
problems in the real world?"
And found Lockheed Martin.
And had a lot of fun there
for a few years, had a lot of impact.
But it was also a conservative culture.
Where it's hard for a 21 year old
to take on increasing amounts
of responsibility.
So, I went to business school to retool,
and this was in 2008.
And I, sort of, came upon two trends.
I was interested in cloud and data
In cloud, it was the early days
of things like Amazon Web Services.
But they were a thing at that point.
And I said,
"You have to be a big company
to play in this game."
And data. And the more I looked
at this field of big data,
the more I realized,
"Hey, I think I know a thing or two
about this topic."
I feel just from reading the trade rags,
like I could be useful here.
Yeah.
So, when summer came around,
I just found every single
big data company I could.
And one of them was called Cloudera.
They had about 12 employees.
Oh my God.
And I called them off and said,
"Hey, can I help?"
Literally I phone called the CEO, Mike.
And I spoke to all the founders.
I spoke to the CTO armor.
And I think he actually thought
I was interviewing
for a software engineering job
in the beginning.
And so, I never had the heart to ask him
how that interview went.
I think it's pretty poor.
So, they said,
"Hey, come help."
And it was just,
there were just engineers.
And so, as we thought about
some of the initial product roadmaps
or business packagings
and things like that,
I gotta play a really fun role in that.
It was a lot of fun.
But at the same time,
it was a sort of deeply deep technology
for technologists.
And I said to myself,
as I was leaving business school,
"Hey, how do we help mere mortals
get some value out of data?"
It's great to help people
that can write lots of code,
but how do we help
less technologically savvy people
benefit from these systems?
And I found Splunk, and I said, "Wow."
Splunk is sort of this vertically
integrated big data application.
They didn't call themselves that.
But that's in effect, what they were.
They were serving
mostly assistant men
or IT people. Still deep.
But  maybe not quite as deep.
And I saw, I had a vision.
I saw the ability for them
to use this platform
to service even less technically
sophisticated people over time.
So, I joined Splunk.
And I was there for a couple years
right up to their IPO
and looked after pretty much
anything you could touch.
And then, right around that time,
when Splunk was getting ready
to go public,
I joke that the VCs were typing
into their LinkedIn search box,
"NBA plus big data."
And I was one of the four hits.
In 2012, there only four hits.
And so a large number of people
reached out.
And I decided to make the move
over to Excel,
where I had known some of the guys.
I met them through sitting in
on a board meeting at Cloudera.
And focused a lot on data and analytics.
And so, that daps of sort of knowledge
and firsthand experience
really enabled me to focus
on a domain or focus area.
And which is what I did
when I started at Excel.
I was there for about six years
and then I came over to Wing.
And at Wing, our focus
is really trying to just build
help entrepreneurs on that journey
from zero to product market fit
and beyond.
And so, almost putting on
my product manager hat and saying,
"Hey, I wanna do one thing really well."
There's lots of ways as investors
to make money with consumer funds
and growth funds.
And China and India strategies.
But let's build a product to us
as a VC firm around one thing,
which is helping enterprise
B2B entrepreneurs on that initial journey.
Wow. Okay.
I don't even know where to begin.
I wanna go back to Cloudera and Splunk
because those two are
incredible incredible companies,
Really, innovators, a field
that I'm very passionate about.
And Splunk, what was it like
going into a company
that has product market fit
with a certain demographic?
So, right. Sysadmins and people who are,
still, they're might not be necessarily
the engineers at the company,
but they're very tech savvy.
Today, Splunk services,
any person who's able to just to look
at graphs and just connect the dots.
Right?
And so, what is that like
coming into company
and thinking of this vision
and seeing a product that right now
serves a certain demographic
but trying to extrapolate it
onto a larger market?
Yeah. I can't take too much credit here.
But I can certainly describe the thought
process going on at a product company.
And it's roughly as follows,
people initially at the time,
they actually bought Splunk
for an IT use case.
Today, if you look at their financials,
you might see it's actually a little bit
more slanted to security in many cases.
But back then, it was it was mostly IT.
And you would help people get to this,
what we called an "Aha moment".
They'd find some sort of magical value.
And if you're deeply technical,
it's a super graph.
Where graphing across
all the different boxes.
We're finding that logline we need
to solve our problem.
And if you do that a hundred times faster
and swamped than logging on to each box,
you're very happy.
And most people actually did that
with the free product,
with a free trial or a free download.
And so, they were very excited
by the time a salesperson
actually contacted them and say,
"You know, you wanna pay for this."
Is that generally the case that,
So, obviously, this idea
of the freemium model is that
you try to get your users to an aha moment
as they're just risk free taking a stab
at the software.
And then when the salesperson
comes around, it's easy.
But that sounds like
something very difficult to do, right?
For any company?
Look, one, I think Splunk
was one of the pioneers
in the true enterprise space,
that sort of easy use, quick value
is something that's now become the norm,
the consumerization of Enterprise.
That wasn't the tagline back when
Splunk got started.
And they made a bunch
of very thoughtful product
and pricing decisions.
But they also,
they had a great market.
They just had this opportunity
where you could make
in the moment of truth
when the pager goes off,
you could help someone.
If you're building a payroll system,
you can delight them.
But you can't make them say, "Aha."
And in quite the same way
for the most part, right?
It's a sort of depends
what space you're in
and you help them solve an acute problem
in a moment of need.
And of the back of that,
you were able to build a relationship.
You were able to eventually
have a financial transaction that happens.
And then, the way to think about
serving other users is really to say,
"Hey, you put in X data."
What if you put in 1.25x data,
that's 25% more data
and now you can enable use case Y, right?
And so, that's what security was,
which was the clear second use case.
We have to build more content
for the security practitioners.
Some of them are very sophisticated code,
like Python and understand
the sponsors language.
Others need, they need charts.
They need dashboards to do their job.
And so, we'll build those
canonical dashboards.
You'll pay us for those.
You pay us to put more data into Splunk.
And now we serve as the second use case.
And then so on and so forth.
And I think within IT and security,
Splunk has done a phenomenal job.
And we'll continue building content
to serve as many many other markets
over time.
So, now you're moving on to Wings VC.
And over there, you mentioned that
your focus is on helping entrepreneurs
get their B2B SAS platform
to that product market fit
and beyond, right?
From the very early stages.
So, what are some of the things
that you're observing as you're going
through this journey?
What are some of the common challenges
that you're observing?
Because you're really seeing entrepreneurs
very very early on
as they might have an MVP
and they're trying to get
these enterprises to buy into it.
It doesn't sound very easy to me.
Yeah. What I mean,
so, we have a tendency to work
with deep technological founders
who have an insight about
a particular domain area.
And this might be core IT
or it might be in the real world.
I spent a lot of time looking at things
like computer vision these days.
And I have to tell you that
there's gonna be some value
in core enterprise.
But a lot of the value of these systems
is out in the real world
where you can see things and react.
And some struggling,
there's a lot of struggles
that these entrepreneurs go through.
Hiring the right people
is certainly a struggle.
Most people don't struggle all that much
in hiring the tech talent on
in the early days.
But that initial business model,
that initial go to market strategy,
sometimes that's something
that the entrepreneur has done before.
Often this is a new domain
or that might be
a completely foreign to them.
And so that's an area where
we really tried to roll up our sleeves
and not do, but help and support, right?
And say, here's an example
of a head of sales for a company
in adjacent space
that's at public company scale.
You're never gonna hire them,
but maybe they're great adviser.
Here's an example of the marketing
candidate you're gonna want
in another year, right?
And so, try to surround them with people
and sort of thought partners
that they can use
to continually evolve their thinking
and just encouraging people
to take that experimental mindset.
Sometimes people treat
you're to market like this black box
or we hire a BPO sales,
spend a couple million of dollars
and see what happens.
And, it's two years in
and a lot of money wasted
before you can make any changes.
And so, that's where the area for sure,
where we most repetitively
and deeply engage.
It's not very common for institutional VCs
to come in that early on, right?
I mean, I know a lot of VCs like to join.
And once you have some great returns,
and you have a good ARR,
and you're ready to take
your series A and grow.
It depends.
You should check out the wing.vc blog
if you wanna see some pretty deep analysis
by my partner Peter
that really unpacks those trends.
What I'd say is that as follows,
wing invest in three buckets:
the experimental seed bucket, which is
we'll call it
"a two million dollar check."
Maybe there's some deep
technological risk.
Can you even build this?
Does this market even exists?
We invest in this round.
We call the power seed, which is,
maybe it's a four to six
million dollar financing.
It takes a long time to build
deep enterprise tech.
And some people are marketing these things
as seed extensions or seed tools, which,
in my humble opinion,
is not great marketing.
Someone says,
"Oh, I've raised my seed extension."
and I'd say,
"I'm sorry for your loss."
So, I think we could do better
in branding these things.
And then the classic series A,
which fluctuates a bit.
We ramped up really high in 2019.
Maybe this is that eight to $15 million
check size.
And wing actually aspires to invest
across this entire spectrum.
Wonderful.
And I think you see some large firms
that they sort of dabble.
They'll play in this experimental seed
or power seed phase.
Certainly, in light of covid,
we've seen some people
redouble their efforts a little bit there.
But you're right,
a lot of people are waiting
for the series A.
And 82% of the series A's these days
have post revenue.
And if you look at the valuations,
what are the series As?
These are the series B
is from a decade ago.
That is simply what they are.
And so, this power seed phase
where we have a little bit of product,
we have probably,
we're still pretty revenue in many cases.
We've engaged with the customers
meaningfully.
That's an area that we feel
really well equipped to play.
We're happy to roll up our sleeves.
We're happy to talk to those customers
and figure things out.
With the entrepreneur,
there's some firms that will participate
and engage in such a process.
And there's many others that will say,
"Hey, let's just wait until it's obvious."
Right. So, investing in deep technology,
it's a different type of investment than,
than going mainly of the market
and just the financials.
You're actually looking sometimes
at founders who are who are really,
they think that they've understood
their niche much better than others.
And they are able to develop something
that is cutting edge and that is really
going to innovate on their domain.
They're not just going in
and trying to take a similar technology
that exists and implement it
into another market.
How do you go in about doing
proper due diligence on that?
And how do you, as a venture capital firm,
support entrepreneurs who are dedicated
to deep technology?
Because innately they're spending
years of research on these things
and then you have to come in
and you have to determine
within a matter of days or weeks
whether this is something
that you believe in.
Yeah. The way you describe it,
makes it sound hard.
On the other end,
I don't know how hard it is, right?
So, I have enough
of a technical background
but I can't go toe to toe
with these entrepreneurs.
Maybe I can pretend
for some period of time,
but I can determine whether or not
something is real.
Whether is this BS or is this real?
And then if it's real, we do the following:
one, we're gonna find
the foremost domain authority
to help validate the elements of risk
that we see in the technology.
Whether that's the computer vision,
with the AI,
the containers or,
whatever it happens to be.
And then, depending on the state
of the product,
we're gonna go out
and talk to the customers
and understand what their perception is,
what it is that they have
and haven't been able to validate.
What it is that they may need.
How it is that they're going to procure.
And then we line everything up and say,
"All right, here's the scorecard."
"Here's the risks
and opportunities we see."
"Does this make sense?"
"And do you think
that this entrepreneur
is uniquely capable of navigating
through this environment?"
Wow. Very very cool.
And it's really sounds like
a lot of the experiences that you've had
leading up to the venture capital world
have really come together
to give you this balanced
and well-rounded insight
into the different things you're doing.
Do you feel,
and I'm now I'm speaking
as a young entrepreneur
and a lot of my friends
who are  following this,
they're also young engineers,
young entrepreneurs,
perhaps out of 8200 in Israel
or perhaps out of Stanford,
or MIT here in the US.
And now, my question is
you've had a variety
of different experiences,
both in engineering
and in product management in business,
do you think there are some  experiences
that were more worthy of your time
than others that,
because in my generation,
we have to make a lot of decisions
all the time.
Which companies do we go to?
What fields do we study?
How long do I wanna be an engineer
before I make my transition
to product management?
Just as an example,
it's something that I'm grappling with
and a lot of my friends
are grappling with.
Which experiences do you think
really move the needle for you?
Well, look, it all depends
what you wanna accomplish in your career.
And I'll make two points:
One, it's almost impossible to become
more technical over time.
Once you leave the engineering ranks,
you've left the engineering ranks.
Most people don't circle back, right?
And so, people often rush to get on with it
or become a product manager
or whatever that is.
But for the most part,
that's a one way trip.
So, choose your decision path wisely
and know that maybe 20, 30 years ago,
people didn't really empower
technical ICs, individual contributors,
in the same way that they do today.
And you have to become at least a manager.
Right?
Or your paycheck
wasn't getting any bigger.
And companies like Google and others
have done a great job really saying,
"Hey, there's a path to become
a level eight or whatever it is, IC
and get rewarded for it."
So, like that's a viable career strategy.
Actually, one of the most incredible,
innovative things that I've observed
in the Israeli military
is this exact same idea that
the Israeli military was
it's known that you want to go higher,
you have to become an officer
and you have to grow your ranks
and get your different ranks or whatever.
And all of a sudden
in the intelligence unit, they're saying,
"Oh, we actually have a new method."
"You don't have to be an officer."
"You can be a professional technologist
and you get paid just as much."
And actually, they get paid
more than the officers
and they become this professional persona.
Yeah, well, I mean, if you think about it,
some engineers are not
the most gregarious people in the world.
Some of them love to manage,
love to talk to people.
There's others that don't.
There are two orthogonal skill sets.
And why you would
forcibly lump them together,
creates suboptimal allocation
of talent resource.
100%.
So, one, don't rush to become
less technical.
Two, I think being a CEO
or being a product manager
is the closest that you can get
to possibly preparing yourself
for a career in venture.
And what I mean by that is,
simply that these people sit at the
intersection of business and technology.
They're not just writing the code
and they're not just selling it.
And that ability to sit on both sides
of the fence is very important
in evaluating a business.
I wish it was just filled
with the right technology,
the best technology,
and that wins.
That's decidedly not the case
in the real world.
So, you really need both perspectives.
And I joke with product managers
that venture capital is sort of like
mad product management.
In some sense.
You don't get it right any of this facts.
You don't get to manage
the CEOs in the same way.
But at a different level,
that is how I think about this case.
I haven't thought about
this  transition
and that the product management side
has such a big influence
on the venture capital work.
And I don't believe
that most venture capitalists
have had much product
management experience.
I know some of them have.
A lot of them come from
financial backgrounds, right?
From finance or potentially CEO.
But this is something that
it's very interesting to me.
Well, particularly at the early stage
of enterprise B2B companies,
I think it's a really
relevant background to have.
Definitely.
You're out raising
your growth capital around.
It can still be interesting.
But there's a lot of people that,
are gonna be a lot more facile
with the metrics
and the spreadsheets.
But in that early days,
having a support system,
a thought partner to help navigate
some of those issues
on the product side.
I think can be immensely valuable.
Hopefully, some of the entrepreneurs
I work with have found that
to be the case.
Jake, this was so enjoyable.
And time just goes by way too quickly
on this show.
I always joke that I wish I called it
30 minute leaders
instead of 20 minute leaders.
But now, I'm stuck with the names.
So, I have to hold on to 20 minutes.
But before we go,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Three words that describe myself.
Intelligent.
I think I try to work hard.
I'm dependable.
I'm there when I'm needed.
That's not something
that you take for granted.
Dependable. It's something
that I've learn over time.
I'm there in good times
and bad times.
There's a lot of stresses
as being an entrepreneur.
And you need folks that are
gonna show up when you needed.
Yeah. And also I have to go
for the alliteration,
so, probably, deep.
I wanna go deep to really understand
what it is that people are building
and trying to accomplish.
So, there you go.
I love it.
So, dependent, diligent and deep.
Jake, thank you very. very much.
It was wonderful.
I learned so much.
I really appreciate you
taking the time to do this.
Absolutely.
Thanks so much for doing it.
Take care. Bye bye.